It was the height of the depression and
America was in desperate need of a hero.
They found it in the most
unlikely of places. Butler,
who looked about as beat up as the
nation itself for a race horse,
he didn't have much going for him.
His legs were too short.
Is An Equis too thick and you had a swing
for lag that jutted out wildly? Well,
first of all,
we had a mind of his own when he felt
like running ad run and when he did,
and he simply wouldn't,
it's hard to believe that this was say
horse that lost his first 17 starts.
We'd become a legends.
The greatest resource in history and this
episode of biographics not looking at
a person,
but indeed we're looking at the amazing
story of Seabiscuit the horse that
brought the nation together.
Seabiscuit was born home or accurately
falls on May the 23rd 1933 in Lexington,
Kentucky.
He was the son of a nasty tempered rogue
and namd hardtack and Denzel man named
swing on seabiscuits. Father had greet
speed, no doubt owing to his pedigree.
His father,
man of war was considered by most experts
at the time to be the greatest race
horse who ever was produced.
Although his grandson would certainly
go on to challenge that claim.
The problem with hardtack was
that he was uncontrollable.
Even Hall of fame trainer, Sunny Jim
Fitz Simmons couldn't tame him. See,
this gets mother. It was the complete
opposite of heart attack. She was a calm,
gentle horse with thick knees
and short legs swinging on.
It wasn't very fast though, so she
never raced the cold that she signed.
It didn't look very promising. His
legs were study. His knees were thick.
Antinori sort of funny. When he ran,
even seabiscuits color was against him.
He was a solid,
muddy bay with new distinguishing
white stripe or star on his face.
So these sources,
they were all loans by Ogden Mills,
secretary of the US Treasury, as
well as his sister, Mrs Hc fibs.
They're racing staple was one of the
finest in America with no expense being
spared in the care and training
of the horses. However,
Mrs fibs insisted that only horses that
would bring honor to the stable would be
caps.
The reason that hardtack and swing on
still around was that they both had very
strong pedigrees.
I always hoped that that offspring would
have amazing speed during his first
year.
You best get along with his mother was
put into a 50 acre pasture with Nadine,
other thoroughbred mares
and then newborn false.
So in every group of cults
that are usually two that
stand out, one is the hero,
the better looking,
more graceful and foster one and the
other is the outcast and awkward warranty
looking little fellow who looked as if
he slipped in when no one was watching.
In this group, the hero is Granville
Mans the outcast. Well that,
we'll see this get, but something in
cvs gets to downsize to keen observers.
Several times a day the cults would race
up and down the paddock with Seabiscuit
always at the rear. Yeah. The
gangly colts was never discouraged.
The father and he was left behind.
The harder he drove himself
and the longer the race,
the narrow he came to catching up with
his big heads and short spindly legs.
Seabiscuit spends more energy than other
cults running. As a result of this.
He had a launch wrap or something from
the other cults and even developed a
stronger and tougher leg muscles and by
late that fall he was no longer running
at the back of the pack.
Emerging as a yearling on January the
first 1934 see this gets looked more like
a ragged range pony than a thoroughbred.
He fell to shout his winter coat and
his legs and back where a few inches
shorter than average. In fact, he
was such an ugly duckling. The wind,
Mrs Fibs came in April to
inspect their horses. See,
this guy was as in a way
and an outlying bomb by now.
They see this kid had
found his running legs.
He was challenging
Grandville for the lead.
It may not have had to have the
physical attributes of the other horses,
but it was full of stamina
and determination. So by
mid summer, these rivals,
they were absolutely racing neck and
neck and it was then that Seabiscuit
develops or habits that would be the
trademark that he'd carry for the rest of
his life. Whenever they were vying for
the lead, he would snort at Grandville.
There's an attempt to do bully
him and throw him on pace.
Okay.
In June of 1934 Grandville and cbus gifts
that they were ships to Sunny Jim Fitz
Simmons recognized as perhaps the
finest strainer in the country,
but Simmons had developed a hatred for
seabiscuits father hardtack after years
of being unable to break him,
and there's a vicious habits.
It also given up on the swing
on finding her to slow and lazy.
This it did not bode well for Seabiscuit.
If at Simmons looked upon as a
curse from the very beginning,
he put the majority of his energy
into training Granville while forcing
Seabiscuit to conform. See
this get. Meanwhile, it was
determines not to comply.
He simply refused to go fast.
Finally,
an exasperated Fitzsimmons gave his
jockey a wooden stake and told him,
hits the biscuit just as many
times as you can in a quarter mile.
They run them against Faust,
the fastest sprinter among the group and
trying to escape these severe beating
Seabiscuit exploded around the track
leaving Faust foreign his wake.
He ran the quarter mile in 22 seconds
and two fifths and if you don't know,
this is an incredibly good
time and amaze to Fitzsimmons,
but it also confirmed in his mind that
seabiscuits would only show his potential
under severe punishments.
When on January the 31st 1935 the horses
under Fitzsimmons became two year olds
Seabiscuit. It was tossed aside. It
was put to work. I say Hack Raisa.
On January the 19th he was
entered into a shorter race,
losing by four and a half lengths.
During 1935 he ran a total of 35 races,
losing the first 17 which was
not exactly a brilliant start.
It was only when his jockey stopped
beating him and let him run his own race
that he showed real promise.
He wound up five races setting
three track records in the process.
Still that Simmons,
he was desperate to get rid of him.
Convinced to that Seabiscuit
was an inconsistent,
no hope that on August the third 1936 the
Fitzsimmons entered seabiscuits in the
$6,000 claiming stakes at.
Fortunately for him,
this just happens to be one of those
days when see this get decided to turn it
on.
He won by six full lengths up in the
stands and all the time veteran cowboy and
veteran trainer named Tom Smith,
so heart and courage in seabiscuits.
He decided that he had to have
him a week later to see this gets,
he was purchased by Charles Howard for
$8,000 and hand it over to Tom Smith the
training.
The horse finally had a trainer who
both respected him and saw his limitless
potential. Seabiscuit was subjected
to an intense conditioning campaign.
There was that no one wants.
It suddenly was pampered and
grooms with a focus on foot care.
In order to recover from
the grueling schedule,
you had been forced to India or under
Fitz Simmons as a result of the care and
attention that was lavished upon him.
See,
this gets began performing more
consistently on the practice track.
Either became gentler and seem
to develop a competitive spirit.
He also developed a huge appetite eating
anything that was put before him to
keep his weight down.
Grooms are instructed to muzzle him at
night in order to prevent him from eating
his straw bedding.
A combination of patients,
kindness and skillful training of Tom
Smith initially to transform seabiscuits
courage and intelligence into raw,
unbridled speed,
although is needed now is to match
Seabiscuit with the right jockey.
Smith found him in the form of Jack
Red Polardy Feisty, 27 year olds,
Canadian who'd been roaming around the
West riding and boxing for over a decade
is other thoroughbreds was
as deep as Tom Smith. Yes.
Although the was one of the better drug
is on the Bush circuit had only won
three state races in his life. When
red first entered, cbus get stalled.
The horse was busy munching on Straw.
See this get looked up,
gave us snort and then ambled over to
Paula and rubbed his muzzle against red
shoulder as well.
With that,
one of history's greatest
partnerships was born satisfied.
He was ready how it ended Seabiscuit
into a series of races in Detroit into
races, the Detroit governors
handicap and the Scarsdale handicap.
He came at home first and I think $12,900
in prize money for his owner over the
next two months.
Their winnings accrued to a remarkable
$40,000 a delighted Howard gave him a two
month vacation and then
the 1936 see this get to,
he was sent by rail to California to
compete in his last two races are three
roles. The first it was the bay bridge
handicap despite starting badly red and
Seabiscuit soon found their stride and
they won by five lengths in their last
race of the year for Wells Fargo Handicap.
They led from the start
cruising to an easy victory,
but at the beginning of 1937 as kids was
beginning to develop a reputation as an
pumpin coming champion.
The focus in the early part of the
year was marches Santa Anita Cup,
the biggest race on the west coast.
Seabiscuit started the
year well winning a warmup,
raisins answer Niesr in January.
Then in the San Antonio Handicap,
he was bumped at the start and to pushed
wide finishing a disappointing Beth and
now, well, it was time for the big one,
the $125,000 center and Nita Cup coming.
The home straight Seabiscuit was half
a length ahead of Rosemont the horse,
which had one the week before it.
San Antonio,
but it's Red Polos who
was blinded is right.
I didn't know that Roselands was closing
in and failed to Seabiscuit into the
next year. Rosemont's won by a
nose. This disappointment though,
it was followed by three easy wins.
Establishing seabiscuits gets reputation
on the west coast as the breakout
thoroughbred of the year. By
this time, Charles Howard,
he was making some pretty great money
off this investments, but he wanted more.
He was determined that cbus get to be
recognized as the greatest resource in the
entire United States.
That means breaking in to the far
more prestigious east coast circuit.
So between June the 26th and August the
seventh he entered Seabiscuit into five
east coast races.
He won every single one of them.
He finished 1937 with a record,
11 wins out of 15 races and was the
biggest money on it in the country.
It was also now the most famous horse
in America with the press having a field
day with his underdog story, the nation's
most prestigious and quite an award.
However,
it did not go to Seabiscuit that year.
The winner of the American horse of the
year award was the darling of the East
Coast Psat or admiral who had
just won the coveted triple crown.
Interestingly, war admiral
and see biscuits, they're
actually blood relatives.
See where the son and grandson of one of
the greatest thoroughbreds in history,
man of war, CPS gets farther. Heart
attack was war admirals brother.
In 1937 war admiral won every race he
started including the triple crown.
This prestigious honor is bestowed upon
thoroughbreds that win three major races
in succession. The Kentucky Derby
Preakness stakes and Belmont stakes,
but we're admirals.
Victory of bell mums when it was bitter
sweet and injury prevented him from
racing again for several months or
admiral was a natural competitor.
The life of the activity of race day
seem to fill him with nervous excitement.
He was so competitive.
It was difficult for handlers to hold
him back when the saddling bell rang.
His temperaments was fiery and
skittish just like his brother Han Tak,
but this personality that
usually worked to his advantage,
he never willingly walked into the
gate and once the starters got him in,
he would act up causing
delays and full stops.
At the beginning of the 1938 war admirals,
the best horse in the east and Seabiscuit
was the best horse in the west race.
Fans were anxious for the city of
champions to meet. That's Charles.
Howard knew that despite the public's
fascination with is unlikely star if see
this gives were to be taken seriously
as a challenge to war admiral.
We'd have to establish his
own reputation in the east.
Howard was a must promote them and
it's capitalized on establishing racing
rivalry between the east
coast and the west coast.
He was determined to prove that
a horse coming out of California,
it could be the equal of anything that
ran into the east and it was at this
point that be began issuing public
challenges to Sam Riddle. The own revoir.
Admiral riddle ignored him considering
it demeaning for his champion
thoroughbreds to meet a Western horse,
but after months of incessant media
chiding well, he finally agreed.
The question of it was the fastest horse
in the United States would be decided
by weight of a race to be held at the
PIMLICO racetrack in Baltimore, Maryland.
This would take place on November the
first 1938 the distance was to be one and
16 miles result insisted,
however,
that the race begin with no gate or
a walkup start in order to avoid war
admirals,
temperamental behavior in the gate.
How it agreed to start the
race where the starting bell,
but he also had a condition.
The track had to be fast or dry.
Seabiscuits he did not run well in mud.
If the track was to west because of rain,
the race,
it would be called off.
Then things while they started to
go wrong in the Seabiscuit camp,
red polo fractured his leg while working
with another horse and he wasn't able
to race Paula as good friends
and fellow top jockey.
George to the iceman wolf would ride
Seabiscuit and stat. Up until that time,
every match recent history had been won
by the horse that was in the lead from
the start throughout all of his
races in 1937 a war admiral,
a peasant never let another horse
in front of him. Yeah. Seabiscuits.
He was a come from behind winner or
admirals trainer George Conway and Druggie
Charlie, Kurt Singer, work confidence that
that horse was faster than Seabiscuit.
This men's,
they concentrated on building war
admiral stamina to endure the mile long
distance. Meanwhile, Tom Smith was
concentrating on the start of the race.
He put together a starting bell that
sounded like the starting Bella Pimlico
when he rang the bell. Wolf cracks
the whip on seabiscuits backside.
This condition, cvs gets to run
the ads top speed immediately.
The rest of the century.
It was a worldwide sensation.
The racetrack was so crowded that
10,000 people crowded outside the gates
sitting in trees and standing on car moves
to try and to see the race across the
United States. 40 million
people tuned to their radios in.
Many of them didn't care about horse
racing previously, but now they were.
Kings at here is three being made most
of them while they were rooting for
[inaudible],
Johnny curtsying over on war,
Admiral wore black and yellow silks and
road the rail while George Wolfe with
red and white silks sitting astride see
this Skitch took the outside or admiral
prepared for the race the way he
always did raring up and tormenting his
handlers. Meanwhile, Seabiscuit
commonly headed for the post.
The flag was raised in
the horses lined up,
but just as the start who was about to
ring the bell will pulled Seabiscuit back.
It was a tactic to make war
admiral nervous when they're
lined up a second time
cards. Singapore, this
horseback on the third try.
Both horses lined up at
exactly the same moment.
The starter bell rang and they were off
the two thoroughbreds pounded down the
track,
neck and neck.
It was commonly believed that war
admiral would take the early lead so the
crowds were astonished when Wolf cracks
the whip and see this get edged in front
around the first turn and see this get
was still in the lead or veered left and
took the rail from cad singer.
Then he slowed cvs get right down in
front of war admiral in order to conserve
cuts,
singer,
now we they have to slow down himself or
possible war admiral drew closer to see
biscuits,
but it was still,
I had to buy a length and a
half going into the backstretch.
The distance widens by two lengths.
Then Kurt Singer cracks the
whip and in just a few strides,
Warren admiral was even with
Seabiscuit the crowd by this point,
there were going absolutely wild horses
challenge down the straight and neck and
neck.
Then we're having real took the lead but
only for a moment to see biscuits sped
up. He was once again in front
turning into the stretch.
It was anybody's race rounds rounded
the far town and we're headed for home.
They were a couple of
shoulder to shoulder,
had to had ITI around the
town as they headed for home.
Wolf cracks the whip asking
Seabiscuit for everything he has.
He loosened the reigns
and the horse answered,
dropping his Jen is his pins back and to
race towards the finish line. The crowd,
they were astounded to see Seabiscuit
breakaway by one, then two,
then three lengths in the
end, what it was, no contest.
Seabiscuits was the winner by four
lengths leaving war admiral in his dust.
A Seabiscuit slowed to a gallop.
Thousands of fans burst through the
infield chasing their underdog hero in the
winner's circle.
Seabiscuit was donged with a blanket
of yellow flowers or admirals bond.
That's they're defeated champion
and stepped away almost unnoticed.
Seabiscuit was now not only
the national racing champion,
but the fastest and most
famous horse in the wells.
He easily won horse of
the year in 1938 however,
the joy for cbus get it was
short lived in the next race.
He ruptured ligament in his leg.
He spent most of 1939 healing
and Howard ranch in California.
They come back for both Seabiscuit and
jockey read prologues still recovering
from his own leg injury was to be the
1940 at Santa Anita handicap during the
race.
Seabiscuit got caught in a pocket which
red tried desperately to get out of.
Finally finding his gap. He yells,
now pops, see this, get broke through,
took the lead and definitely goes back.
Yeah.
Following the sounds around the victory.
Seabiscuit retired with a record of 33
victories from 89 races. He had downs.
Charles Howard,
$438,000 and American record at the time.
See this get died suddenly of a heart
attack on the the 17th 1947 three years
later, Charles Howard source
nor one the 1950s sensor.
He's a handicap when it reports have
suggested that perhaps it founds another
cvs, get he answered so that will
never be another see, discuss.
So I really hope you found that
video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe brand new
videos every Monday and Thursday.
Also do check out some of the other videos
over there on the rice and as always,
thank you for watching.